this is steve weintraub with collider
and uh i'm here with the people the
filmmakers the star the writers uh of
the lost king and i really want to say
sincere this was one of my favorite
films that i saw at this year's toronto
international film festival so i just
want to say thank you for the hard work
that you put in to make it thank you
thank you
um so before we jump into the movie i
like throwing a few curveballs right at
the beginning and i'm always so curious
if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing they should watch and
why
well it's it's a story and in this case
it's a good story i don't think so i
think that i would turn your question on
his head why does somebody have to have
seen another film that we have made
in order to watch this yeah this is a
good story yeah oh yeah believe me i'm
telling people to watch the lost king
yes but when i when i when i ask the
question it's more like um is there
something that you're really proud of
from your past that you would like
people to see 50 years work
50 years yeah um
well i'd say i'd say that uh without
picking out a specific piece i'd say
that
that the pieces that we've made together
uh it's about
the interpretation of some
extraordinary real event
so it's it's that's the thing that i
love with the stories that i take on is
you know they work as a really
fascinating story
in any case but then then there's that
caption at the front that said this all
actually happened so that's what i think
that's what i love about this story you
cannot quite believe that a woman from
edinburgh
housewife found the bones
body of a 500 500 year old dead king in
a car park it's all true
[Music]
um uh yeah i mean
if anyone's
jeff steve and i last worked together on
a film called philomena that's a good
place to start
um if anyone hasn't seen that they
really ought to have
if they're uh
if they're if they're interested in film
i i agree and i believe filomina was
also at the toronto film festival yes it
was yes no yes yeah it was great yeah i
remember seeing it when it was here and
i'm like oh these guys are really good
together this is and i'm very again i
i'm a fan of what you guys do together
um jumping into actually i have one
question for you before we get started
into the film what's cooler uh having a
film in the toronto film festival or
playing with coldplay at wimbley stadium
uh well complain
singing with coldplay at wembley stadium
is
whether that's cool or not is an
academic question because there are some
who might think it isn't um it was
certainly a lot of fun and um uh
it's great to be able to do that kind of
uh
that stuff and nonsense of um quality
nonsense it was there but no of course
being at tiff is far more uh there's
more substance to being
tiff than singing with chris martin even
if it is in front of 80 000 people who
are mostly there for for coldplay rather
than me i have to say
well yeah jumping into why i get to talk
to you guys today um
i know that making any movie is a
challenge um
talk a little bit about getting this off
the ground and getting this film made
was it one of these projects based on
your previous work that it was a lot
easier to make or is every film still a
huge challenge
well they are a challenge but
we made this film for pathe a french
company that operates in england and
we've done i've done a lot of work for
them we made phenomena for them
you know they made money out to be quite
honest and so as it were we're it's
easier for us than for anybody else
um i think in terms of uh you know
steven jeff and i are to do lots of
different things on our own with other
people and but we um
you know we we had a successful
collaboration on philomena and uh this
story uh has some some similarities that
it's also about a woman
um
uh battling against uh
big vested interests and uh again
against a huge goliath if you like um uh
and so i i met i met philippa about
eight years ago i think now possibly
eight years ago
um
and
obviously i i've got a long
collaboration with jeff and uh
i talked to jeff about having met phil
philipper philippa langley who's the
subject of
of the lost king
along with richard iii um
so i you know i met her and told jeff
about it jeff was interested and then
you sort of gather momentum and jeff and
i started writing something and then of
course we went to our uh to stephen
because we know we'd work well then
before and thought it would interest him
and um
and uh it all sort of happened
organically
yeah i did not know much about this
except for the brief stuff i saw in the
news and it is such a crazy true story
um can you sort of talk a little bit
about when you're making the film like
this balancing where's that line for
fact and fiction in terms of where you
feel like you can take liberties and
where you want to make sure it's as
factual as possible
okay
i'll answer that it's um
there's nothing in the film
that isn't
um that's unfair or that isn't
either directly verbatim
or a conflation of something so where
where the dramatization would occur
would just be in you know this was a
this was a
quest for many years
for philippa
and it's boiled down to a 90
100 minute film so there's conflation
there's there's timelines that are
squashed um
and there's um
there's also that the really difficult
thing i mean it took steve and i about
kind of
four years
before what's there's a moment in the
film which is why why she gets
hooked by richard iii and there were all
sorts of
reasons in real life
but but it took us about four years but
before we thought ah that that's it
that's it it clicked
so
um and it and it was just a simple thing
of her taking her son to
because he was doing o levels
um
to to go and watch uh richard iii at the
theater
shakespeare
there was a connection yeah so no
there's nothing that's unfair in it and
there's nothing that is
pure fantasy yeah i think we're quite i
think jeff and i are quite ethical about
when we we've you know
actually a few things we made two
there's a few things where we work jeff
certainly works a lot on true stories
but certainly when we work together we
feel like uh there's a sort of um uh
we're quite ethically responsible um you
know we
all the fundamental truths of the story
are
are are
you know intact and uh i think are
pretty unassailable you know um if we do
when the when the when there are blanks
i think hillary mantel said this about
her historical fiction you know where we
don't know then you're allowed to use
conjecture
and there's a lot of artistic license um
in this film richard iii appears
physically to
our hero heroine um
played by sally hawkins uh very well i
have to say um but um yeah so we there's
artistic license there you know we we
bring richard to life even though he
died 500 years ago so it's a it's an
impressionistic
piece it's not a documentary sure
uh one of the things is that uh
i i think your film does a great job at
asking questions about who was richard
iii really and um did you have a
did you when you went in to make the
movie did you have a certain opinion of
richard iii and has that changed from
making the film that's a good question
well in a way that's what the whole
thing's about
uh olivier's performance as richard iii
in the film he made
is social stamped on the world
uh you know shakespeare wrote him as a
punch-back villain
and i guess
people like philippa questioned that
i mean i have no idea what they're right
or wrong but they've now they've it's
actually gone further and they've now
discovered one of the princes
one of the little princes in the tower
wasn't murdered because he's buried in
an english churchyard
so the whole thing is being
undermined in fact there was an english
novel which
started questioning this quite a long
time i mean before my time as it were
so i'm called the daughter of thailand
josephine
yeah so
you know there is an alternative view
yes that's what it is we're not it's not
like there's a big political mission to
sort of say this is what we think of
which that it's all wrong it's
questioning why people are painted in a
certain way and philippa herself you
know the um people are sort of put in a
box and and
and carrick caricatured and uh
uh which
and philippa herself i identified with
with richard in that respect because she
felt she'd been judged uh harshly if you
like and um it's more about you know why
people are are caricatured like that
historically and otherwise you know
the tudors came after uh
richard iii and it was in there after
the plantagenets and then it was in
their interests to demonize
the the powers that had existed before
including richard iii um because it
served their purposes so
we're just of um we hope the film shakes
things off a bit but it's ostensibly not
really about richard iii it's more about
you know it's about a woman who
goes on a search goes looking for
richard iii and finds
herself finds out who she is
um i am a big fan of your work and i
think that one of the strengths is the
way you work with actors i always buy
into the performances in your films and
i'm curious if you talk a little bit
about how you actually like to work with
actors on set and before you step on set
yeah i'm always slightly embarrassed by
this question i would just say well i
hired them
and i've thought about why we're going
to this person rather than that person
when people are well when actors are
well cast they become very happy and
very confident and they respond
if they're
unhappy or they give you a bad
performance then you're in real trouble
but the mistake is always mine if i've
cast someone wrongly it's my fault well
do you want to talk a little bit about
how he worked with you well i mean
but stephen i mean
my role's quite odd because i'm an actor
in it and i'm also one of the writers
in fact stephen sometimes would stand
next to me and shout writer and then go
oh there you are
which never was never not funny um but
uh
i i always felt that very very
comfortable with stephen he's not he
doesn't say
very he doesn't i always find it
debilitating if a director
does a long long deconstruction of how
he wants something done because after
about 30 seconds you sort of can't
remember what's being said steven's
quite straightforward and simple and and
that's a couple of words like speed it
up a bit slow it down a bit
do it louder
i mean
the most effective direction stephen
gives to me is when he looks across me
and just does that with his hand
and that's that's all i need
you're quite low key in this film so if
you did that you might disappear that's
true actually yeah well i was i taken
the note from the earlier film and
assimilated it into my performance
uh i'm obsessed with the editing process
because that's ultimately where a film
comes together and could you talk a
little bit about what it was like in the
editing room and maybe what you learned
from friends and family that impacted
the finished film it's edited by a great
canadian editor
pierre is canadian canadian italian but
she's actually canadian and i think he's
in this city at this minute well can you
talk a little bit
though about so i'm sure you showed it
to some friends and family
it's just a process doesn't then you go
on chipping away and someone says
something
oh i see you you
you slowly start to understand what it
is you've done it was the stephen well i
think i came
steve is not precious and i'd say that
when he's in the edit because i said
what about if you do that and he goes
well let's try that and then you try it
and uh i remember
we we tried something different and he
went yeah that's that's he he was quite
not
if someone had an idea he would try it
out quite happily
there's no it doesn't it seemed very
ego-free when when um
when uh
whenever i came in there and um
i'd see him put things together try
something and then and then put it back
the way it was before you know um
yeah it's quite it seems like to me when
i watched steven in the edit
it was a pragmatic
process not
not not uh
yeah the the film
the the process isn't that that's part
of the creative process is that that the
timeline i'm sure you know where you're
going when you start a film yeah yeah
but by the time you finish you've found
out where you're going but i don't know
that
in all honesty you know at the beginning
when they say what's your film about
what was your vision film i don't know
what people are talking about when they
ask me that question
but slowly you work it out and you have
some instinct
that i guess it'll end up in an
interesting place and there's something
inherently interesting
to what's being written i i think this
was a an edit though to go back to your
question which needed every
uh every step of the process
before it
took flight and and became
the film it is uh so obviously there's
the edit then there's then there's the
uh the dub the grade and the music
and i and i think once all those
pieces were in place
then it just took off
i think it's a miracle that films get
that are successful at all because
for it to work almost well everything
has to
go right and for it to to fail
only one or two things have to be wrong
and because when everything works it
becomes more than some of its parts it
sort of exponentially grows into
something yeah uh that you the slightly
under control but uh but generally um so
it it always amazes me when it
when it does all when it all comes
together was philippa a challenge to get
on board or was she immediately when she
you know knew your work and she said oh
you guys might be able to handle this
she she took some um
she took some persuading because um
luckily steve was not long after we
finished philharmine and steve
reached out to
philippa
and she'd had other offers
um
she was um
she was she was an intelligent woman uh
very determined she'd been through a lot
and um she wasn't about to let
the uh process of the
film about her life being repeating what
happened with what happened after she
found richard iii yeah i think she
didn't want us to make another
caricature like did that sort of do a
richard the third job on her yeah um i
think she was concerned that we might
trivialize her um in the way that she
had been trivialized by others
um but we um but but
and i can see she thought there was a
danger because of course we wanted to
make a feature of her and me she wants
it to be all about richard iii we want
it to be about her and richard and uh
and so so uh and she's she has an
eccentric
uh
quality
that we wanted to delve into um
and that can make someone uh vulnerable
and that's counterintuitive for someone
who doesn't want to be um
perceived as as uh weak
so um but the film uh celebrates
philippa
uh so but to to get to that point of
celebration where you sort of elevate
someone
you have to sort of go through a
challenging journey to get there and so
uh
so but once she understood that it was
basically going to
um
be
in her favor and then she was happy for
us to go on this little journey where we
look at her personality if the
film is
hopefully the end of a very long journey
for her you know what a massive
stop along the way was finding richard
but then you know the the
credit and the claim that she was due
was sort of
she was edged out of the picture she
wasn't really given um
you know proper recognition for what
she'd done and and this
film is redresses that this film is the
end of that journey that's true i did
say to philip but this film will be the
end of your story is that the film is
part of her story now it's it's the it's
the the coder to uh to her to her
odyssey i i am so curious what
has she seen the film yes and what was
it like showing her the film because i
think she should be incredibly like
happy with the result i think this film
does a great job at shining a light on
everything she did um but what was it
like actually waiting for her to finish
the film
knowing you know this is her story
were you there that day
no no i met her i met two days ago i was
i was there that night the first time
you met her
two days ago really that was a conscious
decision
i didn't want to meet him too confusing
but i said did we get it right she said
absolutely yeah sally met her um it was
it was there was a
deafening silence because of she was
sitting right in front of me
and she couldn't respond and she said
can she had her sons and her husband
ex-husband with her and so we just
walked out of the theater and it was a
good
half an hour 40 minutes and she was very
she was i think run over by it
but gradually
you know
those around her talking about it and
then she watched it again and she's very
happy with it but it it was a trauma i
guess it is quite traumatic because it's
very exposing to see your your life and
your inner turmoil depicted on a big
screen um
yeah that's an odd experience i'm sure
foreign
richard
appears
as an apparition played by harry lloyd
but um that wasn't just that wasn't just
stephen i think you know that let's do
that because it'll be funny or whatever
talking about where things come from
that was because she let slip that
during the the journey she would have
conversations with him in her head
thinking what would what would you say
if this happened or what would you think
about this
and then in the end it took us many many
years i guess of pain but we thought
that's the way to unlock that
um
um
and and you know she was really happy in
the end with how we did it because
there's some humor in it as well i mean
you know that was a big thing with you
wasn't it you didn't want it the last
thing you'd want for this piece is to be
po-faced well it's such a dark story
yeah it is mad it's it's yeah i think
well i always like i like
i love the fact i work with jeff and
i've worked with stephen is that you can
you can do something that has substance
yeah but that but it but you can make
people laugh along the way and and you
can
you know you can you can say something
worth saying and entertain people at the
same time and that's
yeah that's that's all you can hope for
oh completely you guys um work very very
well together so i have to ask are you
and please tell me the answer is yes but
are you talking about doing anything
else together in the not so distant
future
or always we always talk we're always
talking about something and for all the
things you talk about you know like to
two percent of what you talk about she
ends up being made but but but yeah i
mean i think we uh
we can't we
sometimes stephen comes to us sometimes
but the things that we work together
it'll be
the final arbiter will be stephen
is is he does he think there's something
in there he wouldn't stephen wouldn't do
anything with it with us unless he
thought he was good whoever we are yes
and however much he enjoys our company
yes um he uh he it you know it has
surpassed muster he's quite i think he's
quite there's no old school
you know he's
and also i think on both scripts
uh steven's you know it was quite quite
a good
hard task master saying what you know to
say what's this scene about what's it
supposed to be doing you know it's just
so there's
there's at least some clarity on on
whatever the road map is that uh
uh so
it's worked well i think it works well
this time
are you really that uh i was going to
say i was going to make a joke but
i'm so you'll feel free no i'm not funny
sir i i wish i had that sense of humor
but one of the things that i'm always
curious about is how people decide or
how a director decides on their opening
and closing shot some directors i've
spoken to give it a lot of thought how
you're going to be introduced and how
you're going to be exiting in others
it's sort of like no big deal and i'm
curious with your work do you give those
opening and closing shots extra thought
or is it not not a big deal
it's quite a long time since i've seen
this film well but even which is the
closing shot but even
though the closing shot is the tune the
tomb and the royal family acknowledging
the truth of what the film is saying
that richard the third wasn't easy but
in fact it was henry the seventh who was
the user whereas josephine
so
i don't think i thought about that but
when i saw it i said oh that's right
that's very very good just like that
what was your opinion
with her wandering around in edinburgh
yeah she's on her way into the office
yes that's right yeah so it sounds as
though there was no thought given
but as with the best of things god is on
your side or sometimes god is on your
own god is on your side i remember in
philomena
for days steve was pacing around
because at the end of
the end one of the end almost the end
sequences that um steve's character and
judy dench's character go back to the
convent where you know the baby was
taken
and
it wasn't quite clicking and then by
magic there was snowfall
and he said i've got my end sequence and
it was like well done for arranging that
snow sleeve
yeah that's true yes that happened that
was that really yeah you have to have
god on your side you don't have god on
your side forget it yeah because we went
back and re-shot a scene and put fake
snow into yes the real snow that had
fallen by chance but it was it was it
was magic it was i'm sure stephen did
have a word with someone up there
i need something doing here can we have
a snow down and then it worked
beautifully if you don't mind i'm going
to ask each of you an individual
question uh i'm so curious what your
next film is going to be i read that you
might be doing billy wild billy wilder
and me um is that going to happen or are
you working on something else
in the meantime i'm doing a job for hbo
written by the people who write um
the rupert murdoch one success session
um but then i
hope one you know
fingers crossed to make the film about
billy wilder it's a wonderful wonderful
script and project what is the if you
don't mind me asking what is the hbo
project it's about an eastern european
dictator
um an imaginary one played by kate
winslet
which seems to be as many of the right
qualities
uh are you filming now or soon no we
shoot in january
i will leave it there and just say i'm
very happy i'm looking forward to
watching it um individual question if
you don't mind um i read about the
iceman yes is that so you filmed this no
no the iceman is hopefully gonna start
shooting towards the end of this year
what's filming now is a four-parter
about cary grant
really aka archibald leech it's called
archie and it's uh
it's a it's a
fascinating detail about his life
uh won't say too much more than that but
uh jason isaacs plays cary grant
i i enjoy jason's work um is this being
done in the uk or is this a look who's
uh producing it who's making it it's uh
it's it's a uh a streamer and
terrestrial television co-pro
and it's being yes it's being shot in
the uk and spain
uh and with the ice cream spain espana
doubles for los angeles all right now
you're giving it all away aren't you all
right sorry anything i can do to
undermine him it's not got your hbo
budget all right yes it's so funny
though because i um i spoke to someone
involved in marlow the upcoming liam
neeson film uh where he plays you know
philip marlowe and they shot spain for
1920s los angeles yeah and i i found it
fascinating yeah we're sort of doing the
same right well yeah
1920s till the 1960s
my individual question for you um so you
i read about the reckoning and you're
playing uh
i'm like you're looking at me like maybe
i got that right no that's fine right so
was there any apprehension about playing
jimmy or was there because he's called
him jimmy savile this has been too
familiar
sorry you're right but i mean was there
any hesitation because he i really used
this term but he was a monster yeah and
a pedophile yeah um was there a debate
on taking on that role uh well i thought
long and hard about it jeff produced it
um
and uh you know i i didn't say yes
straight away um but i thought it but
you know it was very well written the
cast the the supporting cast i had were
exemplary uh so it had all the right um
uh all the things in place to make it
something worthwhile and not
exploitative or
prurient or morbid um
uh so i think it's a it's
and the script was very good and there
was a lot of care taken over it and uh i
felt like i could do it
um
you know he's uh
he provokes a very very
the real revulsion uh when i said i was
doing a lot of people wondering why
we're doing it but as all these things i
think people
it's a he is a was a fascinating
man and was able to hoodwink a whole
nation
uh because he was so famous and
successful and was at the time well
loved by people before they discovered
the awful truth about him um but that
that that by itself is uh
is i'm of the mind that you know to to
sort of prevent these things happening
again you have to look at them it's like
an uncomfortable
process but you you sweep things under
the carpet and try and turn your back on
someone like this then i think the
people a lot of the reporting is because
people feel
the whole nation was either hoodwinked
or if you're being less kind complicit
in enabling
him to do the nefarious things he did
and so
um
so it's important to look at
someone like that i think it's
interesting you know people play hitler
and play serial murderers and no one
bats an eyelid but there's a lot of
consternation about me doing this um but
i thought but um as an acting job it was
uh you know it's sort of what all actors
want to do is play
um you know whatever your views on him
uh
a fascinating
um
although you know horrific but certainly
a fascinating figure
who
really is a manifestation of something
else that was so deeply wrong in
british society i think that's why it's
not just about him it's about what kind
of
uh
society um
lays the groundwork for someone like him
to to operate so anyway i mean i think i
think once it comes out it'll it'll
vindicate itself i think it's oh i
actually agree with everything you said
and i think that it is important for
these stories to be made because and be
told because look at it even today with
athletes who do terrible things and
because they make so much money for
certain people they get away with some
really questionable things or the
weinsteins and everything's about power
yeah you know
but anyway i just wanted to say awesome
i was in toronto i was with harvey
weinstein
i there's a lot to say there but i'm
just going to leave it and say that oh
go on elaborate
another another monster um i just want
to say for everyone watching uh how much
i loved this movie and i really hope
that everyone at tiff gets to enjoy it
and everyone watching at home seek it
out when it is eventually out and thank
you so much for coming in today to talk
about it can i say can i say one thing
of course
somebody a film critic when dangerous
liaisons came out
someone in toronto i assume it was a
filmmaker said watching this film is
like eating chocolate in bed and i've
always wanted to thank that person
how lovely
uh thank you i really mean it when i say
uh
i think the the lost king is is similar
it's like eating biscuits in bed
on the couch not quite as good yeah but
still enjoyable i i'm i'm i really i saw
a lot of movies where i got here this is
one of my favorites i really mean that
sincerely and i don't i don't say that
casually thank you so much you guys have
to go to your next interview
thank you i really appreciate it